we've got first piece of information
about the leadership contest Anna and
that is that Jeremy Hunt the newly
appointed Chancellor will not stand in
this contest presumably he feels he's
got an enormous job to do trying to work
out what cuts to push through probably
for this statement that's due to be
happening on October the 31st to
reassure the markets to show that
Britain can live within its means but
Jeremy Hunt will not stand in this
contest taking one of the big beats to
the conservative party out of the frame
and leaving the way presumably for
discussions between Rishi sunak who I
was told this morning is very very up
for the job uh Penny Morden who's been
making it clear in her public
performances that she's up for the job
sowella Braverman who resigned critical
of Liz truss in a move that many of her
allies suggests that she might be up for
the job the question is which will stand
aside and which will survive in a
contest that goes back to the way
contest were run before 2000 before the
rules were changed in a contest that
will be determined only by conservative
MPS so it's going to be an enormous week
inside the houses of Parliament and in
the tea rooms and bars and the WhatsApp
groups of conservative MPS as they try
to work out which of the names they can
rally behind for the next prime minister
who will be presumably installed in
about a week's time when Liz trust steps
down as prime minister she's gone as
leader of the conservative party she has
informed the king but there is now a few
days for the conservative party to sort
itself out kierstama pointing out that
the third having a third prime minister
in this Parliament should mean that we
now have a general election conservative
MPS absolutely desperate to avoid that
and so they will be trying to put
personal and political differences aside
Jeremy Hunt presumably won't be taking a
great deal of part in that there's an
interesting question Anna about about
quite what this means for Jeremy Hunt in
the sort of medium to long term if he
doesn't take part in the contest over
the next few days has he been given some
kind of assurance that he might stay on
as Chancellor stay on to do the package
of cut that is on October 31st or we're
still expecting on October 31st is he
expecting to be Chancellor at that point
that he's been given a reassurance by
Graham Brady that whoever takes over
would keep him there well that is
constitutionally complicated so we're
going to have to wait to see what that
role is that he sees himself doing over
the next few days but there's no doubt
that the arrival of Jeremy Hunt last
week stabilized the markets and nobody
here wants the resignation of Liz truss
to destabilize the markets once more so
I think that there is a lot of uh there
is a lot of uncertainty uh in in in
what's going on but I think Jeremy Hunt
deciding not to stand uh is a signal
that he certainly wants to move uh at
PACE trying to work out which bits of
government dependent Department budgets
to cut and all the rest of it while the
rest of the conservative party
presumably goes into a high intensity
high intensity frenzy and I think if you
step back from the personalities
involved there are a big big policy
questions uh that will be kicked around
at lightning speed in this leadership
contest Liz trust came in and spent 44
days in power with a very particular
ideology that reflected a certain strand
of libertarian conservative thinking
will Tory MPS just now reject that
outright will they say that has failed
candidates potentially like Zoella
braveman not that far away from a lot of
the things that Liz truss was doing
could they end up with a with a
candidate for prime minister that's a
bit closer to what the kinds of things
that Liz trust espouses perhaps at a
slightly slower Pace or do they do a
sharp handbrake turn and having rejected
Rishi sunak uh just at the start of
September do they then decide that
actually as the polling of conservative
party members suggest actually that he
is the right answer given that this is
an economic crisis given that the
warnings that he made turned out to be
true about Liz truss's plans and given
that he's been quietly biding his time
not really causing any difficulty in the
public eye he's been having a few quiet
conversations with colleagues that
supported him on the leadership contest
he has been seen a little bit in Port
Keller's house in Westminster a little
bit on the party circuit last week
having conversations both with Tory MPS
and notably at a Bloomberg party with
Rachel Reeves so he's just been there in
the background I I suspect the other big
figure in this leadership contest at the
moment as we go into get out of the
starting blocks as Penny mordant she of
course did that barnstorming uh Speech
48 hours ago in the Commons standing in
for Liz truss who was asked to justify
some of the economic chaos she sent
Penny Morton in her place famously Penny
bordent uh said that Liz trust wasn't
under a desk but um Liz trust turned up
much later on uh in that statement as
Penny Morton was defending her but I
think quite a lot of MPS are attracted
to Paddy morden's bombast to her ability
in the chamber to her wit and to the way
that she can dispatch uh political
opponents with a sort of bigger and
firmness that perhaps isn't seen uh it's
not necessarily one of the strengths of
maybe Rishi sunak or even or even Liz
trust so so I can see that Penny mordant
can hold some attraction for MPS but the
question during the leadership contest
so often was yes but what do you think
about economics and does that mean that
she's the right person uh to hold the
room at this point in time given this
particular set of challenges they're
could be wild cards we could have others
and we are just going to have to wait
and see